hi and welcome to serverless migration
station i'm wesley from google joined by
martin to help you modernize your apps
running on one of our serverless compute
platforms in this and the next few
migration modules our little friend
porter will take you on a journey to
migrate from app edge and task queues to
cloud tasks that said this video won't
feature any migrating at all oh really
wes why not i thought this was the
serverless migration video series uh
what's up with that oh you caught me
martin
yeah usually porter does take users from
point a to point b but here in module 7
we need to take a detour first to
reacquaint folks with app engine task
keys we'll add their use to the module 1
flask app engine ndb app then we can
migrate it to cloud tasks ahead in
module 8.
okay i get it so we're going to take one
of our original python 2 apps add app
engine task queues to it and then learn
how to migrate to cloud tasks yep you
got it martin in module 1 we migrated
from app engine's web app 2 framework to
flask a popular framework in the python
community while web app 2 apps run on
app engine flask apps run on app engine
and most other hosting services so pause
here to review the module one video and
do its code lab to reacquaint yourself
with that migration because this module
picks up where that one leaves off ah
yes uh i remember that migration uh so
what are we going to use task queues for
in our sample app wes yeah glad you
asked martin well you know our app
creates a new entity for each page visit
because it only shows the 10 most recent
visits there's no need to keep all the
old ones right why take up all the extra
space and possibly exceed our data store
free tier and possibly have to pay
well we'll have to add a task that
deletes all visits older than the oldest
one shown
okay i have to be honest
i haven't used app engine tasks cues in
quite a while
can i get my hands dirty and do it
myself while you're showing us on screen
absolutely go and grab your module 1
code if you did the code lab or clone
the repo or download the zip file if you
didn't pause here if you need to do that
module 1 is where we'll start if you
want to do this by hand with me now or
on your own time please follow the
module 7 code lab ready let's go to the
computer now and do this
since we're only adding the use of task
keys to our app there are no changes to
any of the config files python 2 users
should ensure your lib folder is intact
if not or you're unsure just delete it
and rerun the pip install command
since it's always good to start from a
working app use gcloud app deploy to
redeploy the module 1 app and ensure it
works before we update it this is one of
the few modules where the app will look
and work slightly differently when we're
done
to delete the oldest entries we'll use
some time stamp utilities like those in
the time and daytime modules we're also
going to be adding logging to help debug
most importantly we need to add the task
you api the imports are in the best
practice ordering of standard library
packages first followed by third-party
libraries then finally local libraries
and everything in alphabetical order
since we only care about older visits
not shown to the user it has nothing to
do with when visits are created so store
visit stays the same the actual fetching
of most recent visits hasn't changed
either but instead of returning with the
data right away let's use the timestamp
of the oldest visit and delete
everything older than that we'll save a
human readable log entry and save it for
the user that's followed by the most
important part creating the push task to
do the work passing in the timestamp and
the handler the task should post to
once the task is added return the data
like before but also include the oldest
visit timestamp when the task runs the
task you serve sends an http post to the
handler trim so let's move to that now
flask routes default to http get but
tasks are posted to their handlers so
that's why trems decorator is designated
that way to start it grabs the oldest
entity timestamp we got from fetch
visits next it queries for all entities
older than that we don't need the data
so just ask for keys only to speed it up
if old visits exist log how many we're
deleting and do it otherwise log there
aren't any and that's it for the task
the main handler stores and fetches
visits as before but now we have a
timestamp for the oldest displayed visit
to let the user know that visits older
than that will automatically be deleted
both the data and oldest visit timestamp
are sent to the template for rendering
but before we do that we better update
that template
the majority of the template stays the
same but check for a timestamp if so
show that older visits will be deleted
because it checks for the existence of
the timestamp this template can be used
in other modules because there are no
side effects if the timestamp isn't
there and those are all the changes
necessary to add push tasks to our
existing app if you did everything
correctly and redeploy the sample app
you should now see an additional message
down at the bottom letting users know
what visits were deleted by the push
task okay back to the program
thanks for the tutorial wes where should
i go if i want to reacquaint myself with
app engine task queues well martin i'd
say start with the task queue overview
page in the docs while our simple app
only uses push tasks you'll find docs
for both push and pull cues there cool
i'll take a look but can you give me
heads up on what we're doing next
sure martin now that we have app engine
task queues in our app we'll migrate it
to cloud tasks ahead in module 8. if you
want to read ahead check out the links
to the migration page as well as the
cloud tasks documentation you can also
do the module 8 code lab if you want to
get started on it right away or go back
to the repo to either look at the code
or check out the next video and we look
forward to having all of you join us for
module 8 and moving to cloud tasks this
is wesley on behalf of martin and porter
we hope to see you at that next
migration station or on another
serverless expedition soon
[Music]
you